for ocw this has been another year of
great growth and learning
we're honing our publishing processes so
that courses can be posted on the ocw
site more rapidly
as we focus on enriching course content
Learners have more in-depth resources to
pick and choose what they learn in a
given course
as we continue to produce more courses
and resources some of the questions on
our minds are
how do we make ocw more accessible and
more useful for educators and students
how can we Elevate our efforts to serve
anyone interested in expanding their
knowledge
supporting their livelihood or their
community
we've started toward the right direction
by improving the portability of our
content
we're already seeing an uptick in
Learners coming to ocw on their mobile
devices
we want to be even more available where
people are learning and that includes
YouTube and other social media channels
we're also making strides and
collaborating with like-minded
organizations
because we know we really can't do this
alone especially if we want to affect
significant change and it's really our
MIT faculty the ocw staff and our
amazing supporters who are helping us
all along the way
we're grateful to all of you
thank you for trusting us to be part of
your Learning Journey
and thank you for believing in our
efforts to open learning together
[Music]